[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo nous allons refaire
ensemble la semaine politique et
parlementaire avec à mes côtés kathia
gilder bonjour cata bonjour henrianne
cette semaine c'est thierry solère qui
nous donne son regard sur l'actualité
bonjour vous êtes député des
hauts-de-seine également questeur de
l'assemblée pas une dépense de fait à
l'assemblée sans l'assentiment des
questeurs êtes un peu le gardien du
budget de l'assemblée on va revenir avec
vous si vous voulez bien sur la réforme
sur les rails de l'assemblée lancé par
françois de rugy avec un nouveau plan
d'économies qui se profile à l'horizon
cette semaine aussi l'assemblée a voté
une surtaxe sur les entreprises adoption
sous les critiques de l'opposition
droite et gauche confondues et puis la
transition écologique renvoyé à plus
tard nicolas hulot a différé l'objectif
de réduction de la part du nucléaire
et on commence la semaine avec la
réforme de l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'assemblée nationale doit être plus
efficace ce sont les mots de françois de
rugy le président de l'assemblée
nationale a lancé un vaste plan
d'économies
mais au même moment florian bacheliers
député de la république en marché
premier questeur dévoilait une série de
propositions dans la presse une
initiative qui n'a pas été au goût de
tout le monde
astrid de vilaine son comportement est
inadmissible et scandaleux au sein de
cet hémicycle et voilà celui qui est
sorti de l'ombre dimanche dernier
florian bacheliers premier questeur de
l'assemblée nationale annonce dans le
jdd un vaste plan d'économies pour le
palais bourbon
parmi les mesures celles déjà prévues
par françois de rugy aligner la retraite
des parlementaires et leurs indemnités
chômage sur le régime du privé et ce dès
janvier 2018
mais florian bacheliers va plus loin et
propose de revendre l'hôtel de breuil
fraîchement acquis par le palais bourbon
et de supprimer les avantages pour les
anciens présidents de l'assemblée
le premier questeur a sans doute parlé
trop vite
mercredi matin lors du bureau de
l'assemblée nationale à huis clos
il se faire recadrer par françois de
rugy et des députés de la majorité qui
dénonce une initiative personnelle ne
peut pas poser dans l'immédiate question
sans qu'ils aient été préalablement
inscrits à l'ordre du jour du bureau de
l'assemblée nationale
débattue par le député débattue par les
groupes de travail et qu'ils aient fait
l'objet d'études sérieuses par les
questeurs comme par le bureau des
critiques a partagée même par certains
députés de l'opposition
après trois heures de réunion très
contente parce que j'ai vu dans la
réaction du président du rgi la volonté
d'être le garant du fonctionnement de
l'assemblée nationale celui ci a influé
influencé par qui que ce soit même quand
on procède dans la presse en grillant la
prescience du fonctionnement de nos
institutions j'ai vu contre les propos
du castor bacheliers du questeur solaire
ben j'ai vu un patron aujourd'hui c'est
le président d'origine
ok les questeurs travaillent sur les
sujets budgétaire de l'assemblée je vous
confirme que c'est bien la logique dans
laquelle on travaille
l'argent public est précieux comme
jamais et donc j'ai pas qu'il vous
raconte ça se passe très bien maintenant
on a vraiment validé deux prêts
importants bureaux avec des grandes
décisions prises et qui est dans le
consensus
merci beaucoup deux versions
mais un bras de fer loin d'être terminée
le bureau a acté la fin des régimes
spéciaux des retraités du chômage pour
les parlementaires
mais le questeur bachelier a déjà
demandé de mettre à l'ordre du jour de
la prochaine réunion la question de
l'hôtel de breuil et les avantages des
anciens présidents thierry solère on
vient de vous entendre tout va bien tout
va bien on n'a pas l'impression la vue
de son avantage que que c'est le cas
qu'il ya quand même un bras de fer entre
les deux qui aura le dernier mot sur
cette réforme envisagée le premier
questeur ou françois de rugy qui a la
main sur moi je vois pas l'heure du jour
ça se passe pas comme ça et puis ça
m'intéresse assez peu je vais vous dire
comment ça se passe comment ça se passe
c'est assez simple à l'assemblée
nationale vous avez un président de
l'assemblée nationale un pouvoir qui
régit dans la constitution et la mare en
protocole à 13 il vit exactement il est
le président et lui qui assure la police
de l'assemblée c'est lui qui cherche du
travail législatif est il engagé sept
chantiers de modernisation du travail
parlementaire de cette maison qui sont
en cours qui sont en cours ou les
députés sont associés c'est parfaitement
de cette démarche
deuxièmement il ya une astuce l'instant
c'est vers le bureau de l'assemblée j'ai
pas si ça passionne tous les gens qui
nous écoutent mais qui une instance
collégiale sont des questions
importantes
je plaide mois les questions des plus
importantes pour moi à l'assemblée sur
ces sujets là vous allez voir ça va au
delà de savoir qui fait quoi
il ya le bureau de l'assemblée car à des
compétences le président apprend dès
qu'on prend des arrêtés ça s'appelle les
arrêtés du président ce journal officiel
le bureau de l'assemblée à d'autres
compétences qui pourront également des
arrêtés et après il ya le collège des
questeurs sait pas quand vous êtes dont
je suis mis sous les jeunes les hommes
et les femmes il les occupent ces postes
sont beaucoup moins importants qu'il est
que les structures
c'est un collège j'en ai trois on est un
nombre impair d'ailleurs parce que si on
n'est pas d'accord entre nous il faut
plus de dégager une majorité
il en a par ailleurs de nous même notre
propre compétence enchères et le les
sujets financiers les sujets et
immobiliers les sujets
deux personnels de ressources humaines
de cette maison faut que les trois coups
fonctionne bien aidé et que tout ça soit
logique nous qu'est ce qu'on veut faire
et que les questions on est élu on est
nommé par personne n'y a pas patron des
caisses devront mais les questions n'est
pas le collaborateur du président ou de
hockey et l'inversé non plus bien sûr on
est élu par les parlementaires les
économies vous voulez des communes
qu'est ce qu'on devait faire deux choses
on veut une assemblée plus moderne et on
veut une assemblée plus économe des
deniers publics alors sur la seconde
partie il ya 2200 milliards de dettes en
france 2200 milliards c'est considérable
on demande des efforts à tout le monde
d'abord à ceux qui nous écoutent à tous
les français qui ont vu depuis par la
fille des années leurs impôts augmenter
à toutes les entreprises ça dégrade
notre compétitivité à tous les
ministères
on voit dans les budgets successifs qui
sont des millions à tous les maires de
france dont les mairies sont sollicités
il faudrait que le parlement soit le
seul endroit en france où l'on dise non
n'y a pas de sujet sur la gestion des
deniers publics il faut pas veillé à
manipuler l'argent public c'est à peu
près comme économies pour les redonnais
l'état alors il faut donc à chaque fois
qu'on dépense 1 euro soit parce qu on
l'investît ça parce qu on le dépense ça
soit fait c'est vraiment une très grande
utilité
et donc c'est le job des questeurs et
florian bacheliers fait ça très bien
je suis très autres travaillent avec lui
avec lauriane rossi on est donc trois
ont emballé l'ensemble des dispositions
de dépenses de cette maison agir
franchement on ne le ferait pas vous
soyez légitime à venir et l'opinion
publique nous critiquer voilà le sujet
qui me paraît essentielle et
deuxièmement les économies qu'on peut
réaliser c'est pas sur le dos des
députés c'est pour les redéployer pour
une partie d'entre elles et nous notre
objectif c'est que l'autre partie on
puisse baisser un peu le budget de
l'assemblée je trouve que ça serait avec
l'opinion public français que ce que
attendre les français de faire sa femme
mais vous savez moi je suis un député
donc je suis élu tous les segments
et je rendais compte à mes électeurs
vous avez tenu à boulogne billancourt
entend député mes collègues députés
m'ont élu pendant pour un an pour
questions questeur je suis là pour faire
ce que je pense devoir faire je suis pas
là pour suivre le vent de l'opinion
publique je ne sais pas les eaux de
pluie les économies ça veut dire
valoriser le travail parlementaire et là
on va rejoindre les groupes de travail
du président françois de rugy et 2 par
contre diminué la voilure et l'hôtel de
breuil et l'exemple dont vous parlez
qu'est ce que c'est pour dire les choses
simplement en deux phrases on va y
revenir
on va y revenir mais tout à l'heure
juste plus largement c'est une réforme
du parlement aussi que souhaite emmanuel
macron avec une baisse du nombre de
parlementaires une limitation de leurs
mandats dans le temps est ce que c'est
une réforme nécessaire d'informer
démagogique
1 je suis kia parfaitement la non ce qui
avait été fait en congrès à versailles
par le président de la république de
diminuer le nombre de parlementaires de
577 à 400 pour que tout le monde
comprenne bien l'idée n'est pas de dire
qu'on va virer des gens la semaine
prochaine c'est que l'approché
nouvellement législatif si cette réforme
est mise en oeuvre il n'y aura plus que
400 circonscription 400 députés au
parlement français je note juste quelque
chose quasiment je crois voir tous les
candidats de la droite à la primaire en
vue de l'élection présidentielle avaient
dans leur programme la diminution du
nombre de parlementaires alors ça c'est
un point qui fait plutôt consensus en
revanche voilà sur la limitation dans le
temps à trois mandats maximum du nombre
des élus locaux la gérard larcher
réitère son opposition à ceux sur ce
point est-ce que emmanuel macron doit
céder alors d'abord le débat public ça
se passe pas on est méchant on doit
céder voilà j'ai c'est normal qu'on s'en
tape nous d'accord sur tout mais on en
débat on peut trouver des points de
convergence et on verra bien les
histoires de tout ça / g / la sphère de
la limitation dans le temps du nombre de
mandats je suis moi même très partagés
je voudrais sincèrement ce que je pense
si on le fait pas il n'y a pas de
renouvellement de la vie politique
française
pas suffisamment de manière récurrente
un je vous parle pas en ce moment avec
la nouvelle majorité qui vient d'arriver
structurellement et si en fait et sont
le faire on se d'abord en cas c'est un
peu le principe même de l'égalité des
français devant l'élection devant
l'électeur c'est aux français de décider
s'ils veulent réaliser les voilà ça je
comprends et je soutiens c'est cette
démarche
donc ça c'est pour les élus nationaux et
les grands-mères on va dire 36000
communes en france je veux dire ma joie
le monde élus locaux qui sont très
dévoués à leur territoire
il est des dire au maire exemple en
ateliers qui sont des gens qui se
dévouent quasi bénévolement pour leur
ville qu'il faut arrêter ben c'est pas
rendre service à la ville parce qu'en
fait il ya personnel il faut s'y coller
on est souvent contraire bien que les
gens puissent oeuvre inscrire dans la
durée
ok alors autres sujets examiné au
parlement à cette semaine la surtaxe
entreprises dernière création du
gouvernement une inscription surprise à
l'ordre du jour un examen express et un
vote dans la foulée c'est dans l'urgence
qui a été actée à l'assemblée la surtaxe
entreprises mesure destinée à compenser
une perte de recettes fiscales après
l'annulation de la taxe sur les
dividendes écouter bruno le maire est
eric woerth
je considère donc que cette solution qui
aurait consisté à attendre à reporter le
remboursement n'était absolument pas
envisageable au regard des exigences de
bonne tenue des comptes de la nation
la décision que nous avons donc prise et
que nous soumettons aujourd'hui à votre
approbation
ces deux soldes et le plus vite possible
cette difficulté et c'est de demander
donc un effort exceptionnel mais un
effort en même temps qu'il ne portera
que ceux qui peuvent le porter sans
remettre en cause les équilibres
économiques des entreprises qui sont
concernés ce que comprennent les
investisseurs étrangers à juste titre
c'est qu'en france on peut augmenter
massivement la fiscalité au moindre coup
de vent en france
nul n'est donc à l'abri d'un coup de
force fiscale voilà le message que vous
envoyer aux investisseurs du monde
entier
je ne crois pas que ce soit le bon
message à envoyer aux investisseurs du
monde entier
thierry solère les sénateurs ont rejeté
cette surtaxe exceptionnelle ont ils eu
raison
bon moi j'essaie de pas être démagogue
populiste dire les choses en français
que c'est quoi cette histoire c'est une
mauvaise affaire
c'est une mauvaise affaire c'est une
taxe qu'elle a été approuvée par le
parlement français dans la présidente
les filatures qui était pas très solide
juridiquement preuve en est elle a été
annulée par le conseil constitutionnel
donc maintenant l'état doit rembourser
les entreprises
des milliards et des milliards il faut
bien que l'argent est gérée faut pas se
raconter des carabistouilles moi je pars
pas du principe que je ne suis là que
pour voter les bonne nouvelle est que
dès qu'il ya un sujet qui est
douloureuse ah ben non ça c'est pas bien
parce que sinon c'est ce que je fais je
viens à la télévision disant moi en tant
que député je vote que les dépenses et
je veux pas les recettes c'est à dire je
vote pas les impôts qu'on demande aux
français va pas j'ai passé des gens
l'autre ça sympathique la manière de
présenter les choses à la télévision
mais vous voyez c'est pas très sérieux
il manque beaucoup d'argent à cause de
cette affaire
cette affaire et les politiques puisque
le parlement précédent n'avait voté
c'est pas une décision d'un homme
administrative je ne sais pas une taxe
qui est est illégale
moi j'en retire deux choses première
chose à chaque fois qu'on vote et et que
l'un dispositif veillon et ne balayons
passe à notre un revers de main à la
constitutionnalité des choses qu'on met
au vote à l'assemblée nationale et
deuxième chose
aujourd'hui il faut vraiment que
l'effort soit porté sur la baisse de la
pression fiscale
c'est ce que fait ce gouvernement dans
ce budget les impressionnistes sur ce
cas particulier cette entreprise du pays
mais il faut bien que quelqu'un paye 1
c'est l'état c'est nous c'est nous
collectivement et donc c'est normal que
les entreprises payent pour vous c'est
normal je trouve que la solution qui est
mise en oeuvre c'est déjà plié à toutes
les entreprises les grandes entreprises
dans le chiffre d'affaires est supérieur
à un milliard d'euros
je t'assure brouillée c'est assez rare
les entreprises souhaitent il faut un
milliard c'est les grosses entreprises
ce n'est pas une bonne affaire
je vous dis juste il faut bien trouver
une solution parce que c'est un jour
aujourd'hui doit être remboursé et
demander des milliards d'euros dans le
budget est donc exceptionnelle il faut
réparer cette erreur et moi je ce que je
souhaite plus généralement et sage au
delà crédit à ce gouvernement de le
faire c'est que les charges et les
impôts sur les entreprises bas 6 alors
on va parler de la sphère des par
l'audace papers qui s'est invitée à
l'assemblée le gouvernement a été
interpellé sur ces révélations
d'optimisation fiscale à grande échelle
france à sevrey deux interpellations sur
les paradise papers ont eu lieu lors des
questions au gouvernement
la première par une députée de la
majorité le partage de l'impôt est un
des fondements de notre démocratie
il n'est pas admissible que des acteurs
privilégiés puisse y échapper
surtout à l'heure où l'effort national
est requis c'est ensuite l'opposition
qui apostrophe le ministre des comptes
publics
n'est-il pas temps de mettre fin aux
verrous de bercy qui avait vu en juillet
dernier tous les groupes sauf celui de
la majorité tombés d'accord
n'est-il pas temps d'interdire aux
établissements bancaires d'exercer dans
les paradis fiscaux comme cela fut fait
en 2002 pour l'île de nauru ou par le
gouvernement jospin
gérald darmanin affirme la détermination
du gouvernement sur le sujet la fraude
fiscale est une violation évidente du
pacte républicain et j'ai dit au
président ses rangs que le garnement
seraient favorables au renforcement
notamment la déchéance des droits
civiques automatique de tous les
fraudeurs et de tout ce qui
caractérisait son l'évasion fiscale un
discours soutenu par les députés de la
majorité
il faut une la justice fiscale et on a
vu qu'on a commencé déjà à le faire au
niveau européen avec la taxation
notamment des gaffes assurent leur
chiffre d'affaires donc ça c'est un
premier élément après il faut aller
beaucoup plus loin sur ce sujet de
l'évasion fiscale mais c'est un sujet
qu'il faut porter au niveau européen
mais pour les élus communistes il s'agit
une nouvelle fois de parole sur
lendemain ça suffit aujourd'hui que on
met la main sur le coeur et qu'une
semaine avant on est mis en place des
mesures qui vont permettre aux grandes
multinationales de de faire encore plus
de fraude fiscale parce qu'on leur a
permis de faire de plus en plus de
profits et en même temps on s'est pas
attaqué aux moyens de lutter peu trop la
fraude l'optimisation et l'évasion
fiscale de 30 à 80 milliards d'euros
voilà le coup de l'évasion fiscale pour
l'état français
l'argent caché dans les paradis fiscaux
s'élève quant à lui à 300 milliards
d'euros soit environ 15% du pib français
frau d'optimisation évasion fiscale est
ce que vous tirez solaire vous faites la
différence entre tous est ce qu'il faut
des sanctions
dans tous les cas mais c'est comme ça
que j'allais vous répondre je pense
qu'il ya deux sujets qui sont connexes y
sont liés mais ils sont pas les mêmes et
à la fraude
il ya l'optimisation ces pratiques qui
vise à permettre à des entreprises
essentiellement d'aller optimisé en
droit français ont droit au bail légale
mais qui permettent par des effets
d'aubaine parce que des états étrangers
ne jouent pas le jeu et au fonds cherche
à avoir des pratiques de dumping
anticoncurrentielles petit dégrade
l'économie française la fraude fiscale
je donne crédit d'ailleurs à l'ancien
gouvernement d'avoir pris des mesures
claires il
la pénaliser le procureur les procureurs
la république les parquets on aura juste
dix y analyser tout ça est renvoyé tout
ça devant la justice concernant
l'optimisation fiscale
je veux dire au fond on peut s'attaquer
à tous les entreprises d'une part l'une
du cac 40 qui sont cités aujourd'hui
maintenant et toutes ces personnalités
est le plus utile me semble qu'ils ne
soutenaient pas illégal c'est le rendre
illégal et notamment je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec le commentaire qui est
fait par deux députés vont bien devoir
c'est de faire pression au niveau
européen surtout ces pays et la
proposition qu'a fait bruno le maire
c'est de dire au niveau européen mais
tombent d'accord pour sanctionner tous
les pays qui participent près du dumping
à notre égard et qui ne seraient plus
éligibles à des aides financières
notamment du fmi si elle continue à le
faire
je voudrais vous faire réagir à une
phrase thierry solère c'est celle de
gérard longuet le sénateur et les
républicains qui a déclaré sur notre
antenne si ces centaines de milliards
d'euros ne viennent pas dans les caisses
de l'état
tant mieux parce que l'état le gaspille
assez largement et dépensent de l'argent
inutilement comment vous réagissez en
entendant cela et b pas mal
j'aime bien gérard longuet titre
personnel d'un côté je vais revenir aux
sujets d'avant en fait vous venez de me
convaincre
la limitation dans le temps du nombre de
mandats ça peut être une solution pas
mal oui ça peut participer je vais en
train d'évoluer en franchement si voix
la sébile thierry solère la baisse du
nucléaire dans la part d'électricité
produite attendra l'objectif de la
réduire à 50% a été reporté annonce de
nicolas willot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors cette déclaration de nicolas hulot
mais les associations colère écouté les
explications que le ministre a fait
c'était un autre micro
cet objectif qui est nécessaire qui
n'est absolument pas remis en cause
parce que on va progressivement mais on
va le planifier c'est la seule
différence
on va le mettre en oeuvre on va les
faire d'une manière rationnelle
on va réduire la part du nucléaire la
seule chose qui change c'est que
justement le débat à la réflexion la
programmation à la planification elle
est engagée parce que jusqu'à présent on
a posé des objectifs mais on sait pas
trop se soucier de savoir s'il était
réalisable
donc moi je rentre maintenant dans la
transparence dans la vérité on a presque
un an devant nous pour associer
l'ensemble des partenaires et on va co
construire cette programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie donc que
chacun se calme ce qui est important
d'abord c'est d'être dans la
transparence la vérité et d'exigence et
de ce point de vue là rien n'a changé en
revanche quand on se fixe un objectif
puis qu'on ne se pose pas la question de
savoir s'il est réalisable
je pense pas que c'est comme ça qu'on
établit la crédibilité et de la
confiance vous entendez l'inquiétude des
ong vous entendez aussi ce qu'ils
appellent un véritable plan ce qui
aurait dû être inquiet c'est de
s'apercevoir que depuis que cette loi
était votée rien n'avait été fait c'est
quand même curieux que l'inquiétude
surgissent au moment au contraire moi je
m'intéresse à la faisabilité des
objectifs qui ont été fixés
tiens il solaire est ce que c'est un
recul de la part du gouvernement il a
ses raisons objectivement nicolas et
l'au delà dans cette dernière phrase
au fond il loi qui avait été voté par la
précédente majorité qui vise à dire
souvent le comprenne bien
aujourd'hui la france et surtout de la
production par le nucléaire notre
histoire c'est bien du général de gaulle
ne vends ma seconde guerre mondiale
l'idée c'est de dire faisons augmenter
la part du renouvelable là dedans et
mettons une ambition c'est la loi qui
n'a pas été votée la race et une loi
2010 à 2015 et c'est vrai qu
objectivement c'est pas compliqué de
vote et moi comme ça à l'assemblée y
arriver c'est autre chose
et pour y arriver il faut mettre en
place une stratégie et c'est là que
j'avais pas vraiment vu de stratégie de
la partie gouvernement précédent pour
que ça puisse évoluer donc là il nous
annonce 2030 35 2030-2035 dollars j'ai
noté pendant la campagne présidentielle
dans la république n'avait pas pris
d'engagements formels et 2025 c'est vous
dire le fond de ma pensée si vraiment en
2030 voire même en 2035
il y avait 50% de parts de renouvelables
dans le mix énergétique français pas ça
voudrait dire que tout le monde s'y
seraient mis d'arrache-pied pendant 15
ans d'affilée et donc non franchement
mais on a l'impression quand même que
qui n'est pas trop soutenu nicolas hulot
notamment par emmanuel macron sur
l'écologie ce que c'est une priorité de
ce gouvernement l'écologie bah je crois
j'ai vu budget vous avez vu comme moi du
chalet quels sont les budgets comme on
est quand même beaucoup de recul aussi
créer un vrai qu'elles sont c'est l'acte
budgétaire c'est majeur
quels sont les budgets augmentent
enseignements on va les corriger aussi
non je crois pas du tout que ce soit le
parent pauvre il est ministre d'état et
d'un budget en augmentation ce qui est
rarissime dans l'époque actuelle et
encore une fois
l'incantation de dire 2025 2030 2035
tout ça c'est pas compliqué à faire je
peux même vous faire 2019 si vous voulez
c'est un amendement ça va passer vite
ce qui compte c'est d'avoir des
résultats pour les résultats fort une
stratégie et le gouvernement essaie de
s'y coller donc compact
un petit mot sur le glyphosate l'union
européenne qui n'est toujours pas
parvenus à se mettre d'accord sur
l'avenir du glyphosate
la france s'oppose à une prolongation de
cinq ans est ce que c'est un échec de
l'union européenne est qu'une discussion
mais enfin en tout cas mais justement
glyphosate est utilisé très pratiquement
partout où il ya beaucoup de pays qui
veulent le garder nous le gouvernement
français là pour le coup je crois pas
qu'il y ait de problème politique gauche
droite en marche ou quoi que ce soit est
favorable à ce que vraiment vu les
études de l' oms on sorte rapidement et
donc dans un délai de 5 ans maximum du
glyphosate
moi je soutiens cette démarche est ce
que c'est facile non est ce que quand on
s'y met vraiment on peut avoir des
résultats
président la république a eu des
résultats sur les travailleurs détachés
avec d'autres pays européens souhaitent
qu'il en met à sur le sujet du niveau
nat
c'est maintenant l'heure de retrouver
notre partenaire du figaro.fr qui va
décortiquer votre actualité thierry
solère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on accueille jim jarrassé bonjourbonjour
katia bonjour thierry solère je me
permets de revenir quelques secondes sur
le plan d'économies que vous avez
proposé en tant que questeur justement
autant le questeur vous disposez
également de vastes appartements
l'université pas très loin de 10,6 pas
très loin de l'assemblée
est ce que vous seriez prêt à renoncer à
vos avantages de questeur pour justement
pour donner l'exemple vis-à-vis des
autres d'être alors cgt élu pour un an
donc dans huit mois je m'en vais je m'en
vais je remets mon mandat en compte et
j'ai compris qu'il républicains
voulaient récupérer cette ce poste de
questeur je veux bien moi si vous voulez
vous annulez l'appartement mais si vous
pas sûr que ce soit moi qui soit le plus
endeuillé
deuxièmement c'est pas les appartements
des questions là franchement vous ne la
sait les appartements la questure mais
il ya des espaces privés ou imusée
organisé comme c'est pas 400 mètres
carrés d'airé de 16,6 à deux pièces
comme vous allez tous les vices
présidents qui sont logés à côté je vais
également une voiture de fonction
non mais très bien il ya des avantages
spécifiques si encore une fois moi j'ai
d'abord comprenez-moi bien moi je ne
m'engage pas un plan d'économies de
l'assemblée nationale je suis pas venu
présenter ça je vous dis je fais deux
choses avec florian bacheliers et leur
reviendra aussi premièrement j'essaie de
changer des dépenses qui n'ont plus lieu
d'être
pour les anciens présidents de
l'assemblée pour les anciens députés qui
continue à rouler entre 1,58 cent mille
euros par an et de redéployer les
économies dans deux directions 1 une
diminution du budget de l'assemblée
pour participer à la division la dépense
publique 2 m'améliorer le statut du
parlementaire on est dans l'idée de
faire deux choses que je vous ai pas dit
encore on sait si vous voulez je vous le
dis avec laurent battles et d'augmenter
le crédit collaborateur clairement menti
les barmes c'est à dire en gros
l'enveloppent qui permet de salariés à
des collaborateurs elle est plutôt
vraiment insuffisante en france est la
plus basse quasiment tous les pays
européens
ces économies elles ont vocation à
revaloriser l'enveloppent du crédit
collaborateur et deuxièmement
d'augmenter également la capacité
informatique numérique des
parlementaires ça suffit pas aujourd'hui
on est au 21ème siècle et les
parlementaires ne se suffisent pas de là
justement c'est franchement et un mot
sur l'autel de bras et si je peux me
permettre si vous aviez présume en
parler l'assemblée nationale avait prévu
d'acheter
elle avait acheté d'ailleurs à l'état
tout le pâté de maison à côté pour
s'agrandir
ça coûte 60 3 millions d'euros il ya
plus de 40 millions d'euros de travaux
prévus moi je veux bien qu'on parle des
tilles cuillère de l'appartement de
faïence bacheliers mais voyez 103
millions d'euros tout 100 millions
d'euros de dépenses au moment où le
parlement aurait passé de 577 à 400 moi
je ne serai pas celui qui ira expliquer
aux français que moment on enlève un
tiers des effectifs de cette maison on
va dépenser plus de 100 millions d'euros
pour s'agrandir
alors justement cet appartement on
apprend cette semaine que laurent
wauquiez installé son qg de campagne
juste en face alors vous allez lui faire
des petits coucous dans la fenêtre vous
allez boire des cafés ensemble le matin
c'est pas un appartement des questeurs
c'est l'appartement deux assemblées
nationales mais vous tous les députés
lui remet ont répliqué pour beaucoup
moins que les autres c'est les députés
qui s'installe qui qui ont la capacité
tous les groupes politiques et moi en
tant que testeur j'ai ouvert à tous les
groupes politiques mais moins que
laurent wauquiez vous l'aviez cas vous
voulez vous l'aviez qualifiés de
fossoyeurs de la droite
est ce que aujourd'hui vos relations
sont pacifiés où il n'y a rien de
personnel c'est un peu fort comme phrase
mais je le pense profondément donc je ne
peux pas vous dire la verse
j'ai à la droite française n'a pas tout
réussi depuis 20 ans elle a eu un truc à
une caractéristique c'est toujours
d'éditer une dit très clair face à
l'extrême droite et c'est laurent
wauquiez qui à l'occasion du bureau
politique a empêché que la droite
française appelle clairement à voter
manuel macron en faisant ça ils à caser
cette ssii c'est aussi lui je le
regrette profondément
c'est lui qui a obtenu votre tête chez
les républicains est-ce que ça ouvre la
voie à la constitution d'un parti pour
les constructif on en parle beaucoup
mais il rien ne se passe qu'est ce que
vous pouvez nous dire à ce sujet alors
je pense qu'on assiste à une forme de
décomposition de réorganisation de la
vie partisane française on voit au fond
national affaires de monsieur philippe
on voit là glissement idéologique de la
droite française qui ne porte plus de
républicains que le nom c'était pas la
peine de s'appeler républicains pour
faire ce qu'ils sont en train de faire
et est donc derrière il ya une
réorganisation qui va s'opérer effectif
je sais que vous êtes tous très pressée
médiatiquement mais c'est pas comme ça
que ça marche alors politique moi je
suis apolitique la vie politique voici
vous dis que c'est pas c'est trop long
non je suis pas pressé personnellement
des sciences personnel je suis pas
pressé personnellement ministre qui a
une dette qui s'approche et c'est celle
du 30 novembre et puis c'est la date à
laquelle les députés vont devoir se
rattacher financièrement un parti
actuellement tirer solaire vous devait
être rattachée j'imagine
aux républicains à cannes partie
allez-vous vous rattachez d'ailleurs
cette cause est une vraie question
parce que se faire virer par un parti
politique à qui vous avez donné l'argent
de votre élection
bah pardon mais ce moment là qu'ils
rendent l'argent qui touche l'est
républicain a lié à l'élection vrai que
là moi même et de franck riester parce
que ça se faisait de cette enveloppe à
la moi j'ai jamais eu besoin des partis
politiques pour me faire élire j'ai été
élu face à claude guéant en 2012 sans
aucune investiture à boulogne
billancourt et croyez moi je ne vais pas
ça fait bien longtemps que je mets pas
les logos dans tous les sens pour
essayer de dire et voter pour ce parti
moi je suis candidat - deuxièmement la
réorganisation de la vie politique
elle se perd en ce moment je pense
profondément qu'il ya un espace 1 entre
la république en marche qui existent et
les républicains du parti c'est fini
bon bah c'est fini nous arrivons au
terme de cette émission merci beaucoup
tient l invité de par le mans l2 on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine ciao
[Musique]